الآن إلى شرق ليبيا، حيث تضاعف
عدد القتلى بسبب الفيضانات الكارثية
خلال الـ 24 ساعة الماضية،
وتقول السلطات الآن إن أكثر من 5000
شخص يفترض أنهم لقوا حتفهم، وما
زال 10000 آخرين في عداد المفقودين، وذلك وفقًا
للهلال الأحمر،
ويبدو أن مدينة درنة الساحلية  كن الأكثر تضرراً، فقد
انهارت العديد من المباني للتو،
ويقول مسؤول حكومي إن ربع
المدينة قد اختفى، وبعض
الصور من الكارثة مصورة،
والمستشفى الوحيد في أدونا لم يعد يستقبل
المرضى أو الجثث مصفوفة على
الرصيف، وقد اجتاح البعض الآخر  في
البحر، تجري الآن عمليات دفن جماعي في
بعض أجزاء البلاد، ويقول المتطوعون الذين
يبحثون عن الناجين ويهتمون
بالجرحى إنه لا يوجد عدد
كافٍ من الأشخاص لمساعدة الكثيرين الذين هم في أمس
الحاجة إلى المساعدة، ويتم
تقديم المساعدة لأولئك الذين هم في أمس الحاجة إليها.  بل إن الأمر
الأكثر تعقيدًا هو وجود
الحكومة الليبية المنافسة، واحدة في الشرق
وواحدة في الغرب، أفاد مراسل CNN الدولي البارز،
بن ويدمان، في
تقريرنا بأن
جدارًا من المياه يندفع نحو
المدينة الليبية الشرقية، وقد أدى
سدان إلى انفجار عشرات
الآلاف من الأشخاص الآن في خطر مميت
بعد  تسببت عاصفة غريبة في سقوط أمطار لمدة ثمانية أشهر
في يوم واحد،
وقال متحدث باسم الجيش إن
أحياء بأكملها في درنة جرفتها مياه
البحر،
ويخشى المسؤولون أن يكون العديد من الأشخاص قد
لقوا حتفهم بسبب الفيضانات في شرق
ليبيا،
ولا يزال هناك العديد من الأشخاص الآخرين الذين تم
تأكيدهم من مصادرنا المستقلة.  تشير مصادر
المعلومات إلى أن عدد المفقودين
يصل إلى 10000 شخص،
وعشرات الجثث المغطاة بالبطانيات متناثرة
خارج مشرحة درنة التي
أصبحت الآن ممتلئة عن آخرها.
الاتصالات مع المدينة متقطعة تسببت
العاصفة دانيال في تدمير العديد من
أبراج الهواتف المحمولة وتعطل العديد من
الطرق
اهتزت ليبيا الخارجية غير القابلة للعبور بسبب انتفاضة عام 2011
ضد حكم معمر القذافي
ومزقتها الحرب الأهلية بعد سنوات من
الحماقة البشرية والاستعداد لغضب الطبيعة،
وربما لم تكن هذه هي الأولوية القصوى لأي شخص، وقد أرسلت
تركيا فرق بحث وإنقاذ
وإمدادات طوارئ، كما أرسلت إيطاليا
أيضًا  إرسال فرق لتقييم
الأضرار
لكن مستوى الموت والدمار
قد يكون أكثر مما تستطيع ليبيا التعامل معه
بعد ظهر الثلاثاء ظهرت رسالة بسيطة
على صفحة فيسبوك
لبلدية درنة
إن الوضع في المدينة خارج عن
السيطرة وقالت إن
التدخل الدولي هو  مطلوب
بن ويدمان سي إن إن روما